bim bum bam
da lunedì a sabato alle 16 su it up
l'importante non mangiare niente tra un
pasto e l'altro pronto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora
sono cose che vanno al di là dell'umana
comprensione che abitano in quella parte
di cervello che alimenta paura ignoto
terrore quando guardi qualcosa di
terribile ma non riesce a voltare lo
sguardo come un incidente stradale o un
ragazzo che urina e defeca sulla testa
del proprio fratello su youtube la
realtà a volte è più terrificante della
fantasia
esiste un genere di film che sazia
questo appetito morboso della nostra
esistenza
gli shock umentare
[Musica]
lungometraggi che rappresentano la
realtà per quella che è realistica
cruenta devastante 1962 italia mondo
cane film che ha dato via al genere
mondo movies docu film in cui si
mostrano immagini violente scioccanti ed
erotiche in giro per il mondo dagli anni
60 fino alla fine dei 90 ne sono usciti
molti grandi classici come dipingi di
giallo il tuo poliziotto i vizi segreti
degli italiani quando credono di non
essere visti e il bello nel mondo
a volte questi documentari possono
essere uno spaccato della nostra società
programmi televisivi come cox in cui una
troupe segue i poliziotti americani
durante le routine giornaliere tra
arresti e sparatorie il taglio
realistico del tutto rende inquietanti
anche le giornate normale a volte invece
possono scoprire corde della nostra
anima che non sapevamo di avere face of
death per esempio film bandito da
addirittura 46 paesi diversi che ora
però si può comprare in blu ray su
amazon è forse il più feroce e brutale
di tutti i mondo movie uccisioni di
animali famiglie massacrate autopsie e
orge anche se parte del contenuto sono
ricostruzione si dice che in giappone il
film sia stato per dieci settimane
campioni di incassi superando star wars
tanto che sono stati prodotti altri sei
seguite tutte questi film tra gli anni
90 e gli anni 2000 sono circolati
tramite bootleg vhs o dvd che contengono
film o spettacoli senza autorizzazione
il termine tecnico italiano dovrebbe
essere pezzotto per rendervi l'idea
questa è la locandina di star wars
episodi uno ufficiale questa con arnold
schwarzenegger è un bootleg il dvd di
cui parleremo oggi è in show ringhia
your place in hell assicurarsi un posto
all'inferno un misterioso ed esplicito
dvd che contiene quattro filmati degli
anni 90 girati in bus
premio e finalmente sono in possesso di
una copia
abbiamo tenere in auto qualcuno di quei
ferrero rocher mi ero permesso di
pensarci su questo dvd appare solo ogni
tanto negli store online
dipende dal periodo a volte potrebbe non
essere disponibile da nessuna parte
dopo ore di ricerca l'ho finalmente
trovato sul sito ai hoffer
[Musica]
acquistato il 05 05 2010 7 aspetto
giorni e non arriva nulla
19 05 2017 arriva una mail ai ricevuto
il tuo a questo no non ho ricevuto il
mio acquisto
04 06 2010 a 7 per favore valuta al tuo
acquisto
tre anni dopo non solo scopro che hai
hoffer ha chiuso come sito di vendite ma
era anche valutato pochissimo su
trustpilot truffatori dice la gente
bravo [ __ ] mi dico io ma nel 2019 un
sito mi cade sotto gli occhi più thread
production un sito ricolmo fino all'orlo
di dvd shock e gore alla scrittura di
questa puntata è rimasta pochissima roba
nel catalogo ormai sono rimasti soltanto
dvd di autopsia umane e libri di
fotografie di animali investiti in mezzo
alla strada
forse troppo macabro per voi magari vi
interessa il loro merchandise con il
disegno di due gemelli siamesi soltanto
la polizia postale lo può sapere
la curiosità era molta in quel 2019 ma
prendo fiato e ne compro soltanto due
assicurarsi un posto all'inferno e il
rambo turco sarebbe bello se qualcuno
facesse la recensione di questo film ma
queste storie macabre non sono tali
senza un twist io sapevo di star
comprando un bootleg ma non pensavo mi
sarebbe arrivato il bootleg del bootleg
copertina stampata in bassissima
risoluzione e disco bianco con scritte
nere come i marocchini che sotto i
portici negli anni 90 ti vendevano gli
album delle spice girls
weiss garda il primo dei quattro filmati
del dvd egrave roberz formare ons
praticamente un tutorial su come di
sotterrare cadaveri da un cimitero e un
video molto noioso dove si dicono molto
ovvietà
la particolarità è che nessuno conosce
l'identità degli autori
esiste addirittura un sito che da anni
cerca informazioni su di loro ma senza
successo
ed è un sito creato su weeks mortuarie
of the dead invece è un filmato
estrapolato da una vecchia videocassetta
rovina tissima del 1992 due ragazzi più
il cameraman entrano in un obitorio
molto particolare intorno a loro ci sono
pezzi di cadavere conservati in barili
effetti nei barattoli sembra di stare al
trans il bagno qualcuno si ricorda il
transylvania pace all'anima sua
ci sono molte teorie che girano intorno
a questo video che sia la prova della
polizia di un caso giudiziario che sia
uno scherzo tra amici che sia la
location di un cortometraggio
ma se fosse vero sarebbe una rivelazione
vorrebbe dire che alcuni luoghi medici
conservano cadaveri per farci
esperimenti se ci penso mi vengono i
brividi ni alle ginocchia
il giorno in cui morirò vorrei che il
mio cadavere venisse riempito di
caramelle e usato ad una festa di
compleanno come pignata parcheggi con il
pranzo di natale quattro ori in
exploding farming si mostra come far
letteralmente esplodere piccoli animali
come marmotte topi e simili
fa parte di una serie di vhs su come
uccidere animali dannosi per le fattorie
con l'arma fa arment un fucile da caccia
con una canna di grandi dimensioni
perché scacciarli con la scopa era
troppo classico la cosa che mi ha creato
un mezzo sorriso quando l'ho scoperta è
che il secondo volume di exploding
barmen si chiama mission impossible
l'ultimo dei quattro filmati e cooking
with us boat coni e questo filmato in
cui un ragazzo che odia profondamente la
sua famiglia gli regala 4 torte cucinate
da lui
[Musica]
la prima la regala al padre mettendo
nell'impasto sputo di senzatetto
la seconda la regala alla madre mettendo
all'interno carcasse di animali morti
uccisi per strada
la terza tocca alla sorella con sangue
di persone affette da epatite la quarta
sicuramente la migliore tocca alla nonna
una torta il cui interno della crosta è
fatto di sperma di un uomo e molto il re
come scena ma basta poco per capire che
è un falso è un cortometraggio del
futuro regista e produttore huck botko
appunto che tra altre cose produrrà
l'ultimo esorcismo e sarà il regista di
mozart un cane per due no lo so lo so
sta diventando il paziente mozart un
cane per due
dal 7 dicembre non so perché a me
piacciono così tanto questa storia e ne
ho già parlato ma è giusto ribadirlo
ogni tanto la particolarità è che non
solo speso un sacco di soldi per un dvd
che non è mai arrivato e un dvd bootleg
del bootleg ma tutti e quattro i filmati
possono essere trovati gratuitamente su
youtube
[Musica]
l'uomo